when I came out visiting first here to
Stanford I worked in a company that was
making a major engineering decision
about changing its product with maybe
hundreds of millions of dollars and
though I had taught statistical decision
theory when I first got to this company
they gave a lecture to they said well
could we really use this to make this
major decision that we have to make and
I said why not and so we worked through
that whole year you know day a week or
something for me on how to apply this to
actual decision problems as opposed to
balls and urns or other things that
decision theory had worried about it and
then at the end of that year when I had
to write it up for a conference and bust
in the head and say well what am I going
to call it and I said well decision
engineering it's probably pretty
accurate but it has this connotation
that you're going to engineer the
decision make it out has come out a
certain way instead analysis leaves more
room for people to to see that you're
going to help them make the decision and
so that's where it came that's where the
term came from that's what I did
over many years we've had many doctoral
students dozens of them in decision
analysis and so we're we like the
teaching of it and these people have
gone on to assume major positions and
start companies all over the place so
what the question was how could we get
people who are ready out there
professionally to learn this in the
effective way because they can't really
most of them come back to the University
enroll as students and so that was the
whole idea behind starting a program and
strategic decision and risk management
which combined the the kind of knowledge
that we get at the University and the
studying we do with the practice out
there in the field which some of my
students do but of course many other
people didn't to anybody who has an
important decision to make one of the
things we say is even though this will
be very useful in your job there's no
restriction to using it in your life for
any decision you might face as a matter
of fact in our in our regular academic
program most of the students who come
back to say how would I solve this
problem are doing it about some medical
decision in their family because the
same ideas that said concepts the same
principles are as useful in any kind of
decision as they are in business
decisions we know that what makes
specific decisions difficult is
uncertainty if you knew what was going
to happen pretty easy to make the
decision and what this particular
approach brings is a way to evaluate in
dollars and cents terms what it would be
worth knowing something that you don't
know in making a decision and I don't
know of any other approach that does
that